tucked away in Budapest vojta Union
Castle is medieval and look but not an
age built in 1896 this architectural
complex was designed to celebrate the
first millennium of the Hungarian state
the buildings were supposed to be
temporary so they were made of wooden
planks and cardboard designs but
Hungarians loved them so much they were
rebuilt with permanent materials in the
1900s the celebratory site features
copies of landmarks from all over the
larger 19th century Hungarian Kingdom
combining architectural details of 21
buildings like the Romanesque Church of
Yaak originally located in western
hungary or the voyda who yad or Corvin
Castle located in what is now Romania
and more commonly known to fans of the
Dracula myth it's believed that Vlad the
Impaler was once in prison there the
name of the Romanian castle ended up
being adopted by Budapest ian's for the
whole compound several Austrian palaces
are represented as well featuring a
blend of Renaissance and Baroque
architecture demonstrating the diversity
of styles that spread across the
austria-hungarian empire and just like
the castles it's built to imitate voyda
who yad is built to be defended it's
accessible only by four bridges
stretching across the surrounding lake
for over a century the castle has
continued to be enjoyed by Budapest
students and tourists alike will come to
relish in this truly Hungarian artifact
[Music]